ce mur situé au fond d'un jardin peut
sembler bien commun et pourtant il
s'agit d'un mur à abeilles datant du
xviiie siècle
un bel exemple du patrimoine rural
bourguignon il y a deux ans les époux
ducret propriétaire des lieux décide de
restaurer l'édifice alors en ruines
j'ai découvert que ce mur s'appelait en
fait la mûre à pied c'est un mur des
abeilles c'est dans lesquelles les
apiculteurs amateurs les cultivateurs
puisqu'ici c'est ce sont des anciennes
petite fermette de petits vignerons ans
cultivateur pouvait avoir leurs ruches à
domicile et de cette manière là exposé
plein sud est et protéger du vent
pouvait garder leurs ruches toute la
nuit
la restauration s'est fait en deux
étapes 2014 restauration des maçonneries
du support de la construction de ce mur
qui sait boulet en partie avec les
poutres et en 2016 restauration de la
toiture à deux versants avec de la lawe
de récupération coût total des travaux
18000 euros
les propriétaires devraient percevoir
une petite aide de l'aser rue 21
cette association de passionnés
accompagne depuis quarante ans
maintenant les propriétaires privés mais
aussi publics dans la restauration de
petit patrimoine rural l'avoir qu'abbott
fontaine moulin ou calvaire au total ils
ont soutenu 150 réalisation en côte d'or
le but initial de l'association
s'étaient de s'intéresser au petit
patrimoine rural délaissé en ruine
parfois et et comportant des aspects
architecturaux historiques remarquables
dans tout le département de la côte d'or
et pour les cas pour lequel le fichier
mens n'y avait absolument aucune aide
possible là des rues 21 compte
aujourd'hui 200 membres
et si l'association fait naturellement
appel aux dons et aux subventions
elle cherche également à grossir les
rangs de ses adhérents